européenne de son côté demande aux états
membres d'accueillir des réfugiés
afghans en promettant son aide
financière la position de la diplomatie
française elle se précise on va voir
tout cela avec et katia technique depuis
le quai d'orsay
[Musique]
bonjour katia alors où en sont les
opérations d'exfiltration française
aujourd'hui
et oui on parle beaucoup de la part de
solidarité de la france dans l'effort
mondial pour accueillir les réfugiés
afghans alors où en est on avec deux
vols dimanche un dimanche soir et dans
la nuit 400 personnes supplémentaires
ont été exfiltrés d'afghanistan elles
s'ajoutent aux 1 650 qui ont déjà réussi
à prendre l'avion et au 625 qui ont été
exfiltrés en avance il ya eu sept vols
pour le moment et danser explique très
il ya des français mais bien sûr de plus
en plus d'afghans menacé par les
talibans alors la question est combien
de réfugiés les français vont-ils
accepter les associations les avocats de
migrants dénoncent le faible effort de
la france dans le domaine jusqu'ici une
pétition a été signée il ya peu par des
artistes pour encourager l'accueil des
réfugiés et en comparaison l'allemagne a
déjà accueilli 2000 personnes et surtout
angela merkel a évoqué la zee pour dix
migrants afghans les américains ont déjà
fait venir dix sept mille personnes de
kaboul et puis la grande bretagne dans
un premier temps s'est engagé à
accueillir 5000 réfugiés avec un ciblage
sur les plus menacés les femmes les
enfants les minorités par exemple par
rapport à un élan des occidentaux pour
l'accueil de ces réfugiés et bien la
france semble ne pas en faire assez les
associations dénoncent des obstacles
soupçonne ministre hâtive par exemple et
on se souvient bien sûr des propos
polémiques d' emmanuel macron qu'ils
souhaitaient éviter les flux irréguliers
alors que des centaines de personnes ont
déjà sollicité la france pour rentrer on
parle d'une liste de sept mille afghans
alors jean yves le drian parler donc des
efforts de diplomatie 2010 et affaires
étrangères a fait une déclaration hier
nous tâchons je vais le site est de
repérer ces afghane et ses avants qui se
sont signalés pour les guider face aux
embûches toutes les demandes selon lui
seront examinés tous les cas qui se sont
manifestés et leur nombre s'allonge de
jour en jour avec des centaines de noms
sont instruits
il assuré les afghans craignent
évidemment une traque des collaborateurs
des français des militants et de toute
personne qui est associé aux occidentaux
une traque qui aurait commencé selon
quelques témoignages locaux mais il ya
une question de temps et de moyens
comment faire venir ces personnes à
l'aéroport qui est sévèrement contrôlé
malgré les documents parfois ce n'est
pas possible d'entrer et arrivera-t-on à
exfiltrer tout le monde en tout cas la
france a déjà un triste précédent avec
des avants qui voulait être réfugié
parce qu'ils ont collaboré avec la
france comme les interprètes de l'armée
française cela fait des années qu'ils se
voient pour certains refusent et leurs
visas d'entrée alors qu'ils sont déjà
menacés depuis de très longues années
par les talibans et donc on suivra dans
les jours qui viennent ses efforts de la
france pour aider toutes les personnes
menacées merci beaucoup catia pour
toutes les précisions katia technique en
direct devant le quai d'orsay à paris